das sind fünf weniger pelzfarmen sie
werden züchtet dass sie so viel pelz
kennt wie nur möglich die bilder einmal
vor zwei jahren
wenn ich winterjacke mit pelz gesehen
trainiert jetzt die richtigen sind
und ich frage nicht ob es für andere
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren habe ich bin finnische
verband gefragt ob sie den hof
vermittler wo man keine filme aber sie
erhalten so hat sich die kamera und die
entschieden dass mit eingestufte werk
machen
[Musik]
dann schnellt mit willkommen zenit
donovan
[Musik]
nach der absage nicht tierschützer
kontaktiert von 2008 mit no go live
beobachten so wie sie das immer wieder
machen
ich habe mich gut an den moment erinnern
sogenannte monster fürs zunächst im exil
stolz sitzt im wald überall hat sie
falten 1000 entzündet sie mit so viel
pelz wie möglich liefere pelz zum
beispiel für kapuze länder
[Musik]
am nächsten tag herr mader tierschützer
tristem uhr ihm einen kaffee prof
mitglieder von der
tierschutzorganisation dokumentiert sich
jahre zustand oft weniger pelz formen
mit denen bilder von einer riesigen für
die öffentlichkeit schockiert
[Musik]
zitat sich vieles verändert fertige
marke antra pelzmann ganze warenhäuser
samples prix wurde zum beispiel jelmoli
abi motto kids cup ellesmere port wird
pelz play und pkz schrieb sie
beförderten frühling 2021 kartells
april laden immer nur viel kaputt space
im gegensatz zu vor zwei jahren filme
finnische marderhund und wirklich viel
viel weniger und das ist definitiv
welthandelsorganisation
[Musik]
erst vor zwei jahren als interview welle
darum die bilder im internet sucht und
tschechien gefunden
nach einer first vermarkten
rund zwei millionen fuchs und andere
pelz sind es 2008 xii ich weiß noch mal
auf finnland will vor zwei jahren hätte
finnische pelz verband versprochen sie
würde kein monster fürst mit süchten
darum will ich gut finde
einzig trab halten und wie es sieht halt
ich vom windows-pc ist offizieller
auftakt seiner farce und der weltverband
aber abgesagt er stand mit januar hotels
firma zieht und das filmteam empfangen
im moment sieht hochsaison darum will
ich im dezember reise ich würde dir mit
anti pelz zu sein nachdem vorher
singkreis ich mit dem zug weiter
vier stunden richtung norden
[Musik]
diese statt wasser watete tierschützer
kristie moore immer auf mich ich stifte
christo und seine kollegen begleiten wie
sie im dunklen ford einen verfüge machen
will einem ganz so viel pelz dir geht
wie vor zwei jahren in finnland immer
noch millionen in traffic control box
von 51
[Musik]
der extreme
waldberg bereitet sich tierschützer vor
angespannte situation blieb es ruhig
der yougov russ und geht über funk
bescheid wenn er verdächtigt oder führt
cd animusx
bis 12
mit der aufnahme von der macht
auf
heute
gut
allerdings liege die konzentration
mit traffic assist minus zwölf grad kalt
[Musik]
ok
mit 14 siegte
bevor man die geschmäcker müsse es
stinkt extrem fest
denn nach einer halben stunde schoss sie
mit peter shafik
doch zu weit
bezahlen
der tierschützerin immer wieder
erschüttert wenn er die riesige tier
sieht sie sind über 20 kilo schwer
der polarfuchs in der wildnis klären
sobik des kurses problems problems die
schweiz werde zwar viel weniger
finnische fuchspelz verkauft als noch
vor zwei jahren gesehen bleibt immer
noch nie holte der finnische verband
schreibt sie sich getraut reduzieren
aber es brauche zeit bis mitte sucht
veränderungen erreicht am nächsten
morgen eigentlich wunschlos
ich will fahren mit martha hinzu das ist
nicht so einfach will es geht in
finnland viel weniger markant als polar
fürs ich bin unterwegs zum einen großen
betrieb
auf derart 2000 hallo
einmal jahres beim 1
wir sind mittel und antrieben zu filmen
ist der kunde mir ist sofort klar warum
er unerwünscht sind
es ist erntezeit
[Musik]
vermutlich werde das verfahren betreffen
wo mich so filmen darum machen einmal
mit tierschützern ab sie zeigen mir
aktuell die filmaufnahmen format
finnland ist einzige europäische land
sucht vor und erlaubt ist ich will dir
selber darum der mit seiner erfahrung
verstärkt sieht
das trockendock grafikformat quintetts
normales das ist gesetz es ist eine
invasive art die tier sieht sich nicht
unter die heimische mission die art von
tierhaltung wäre die schweiz nicht
erlaubt
am ausgangspunkt treffen mit der you
take off your kisses wärmebild kamera
filmt noch einmal voll und ganz die
argenta niemals der atom- oder orcas
unternehmens in pop das kind
[Applaus]
herausnehmen
der finnische verband schrieb das
tierwohl hdd pelz zucht erst die
priorität vor mitglieder wird streng
kontrolliert und zertifiziert
mini druck ist ihr labbadia heftig auf
die bürger in gestand für das vorläufig
nur dekoration ist in der schweiz nimmt
es nicht wunder was schweizer tischen
vor zucht welt halten ich besuche die
thomas deutschem vater geschafft
er spreche vom schweizer hotels
fachverband und frauen bei der meisten
schweizer ruth fuchs für jäger
geschossen
insgesamt wartet das gold auch nicht
dass mit der extra gezüchtet nur dass
man am schluss denen kapuze rand wie
essentiell das thema also muss es so
sagen ich habe sicherlich gefallen
alltag aussieht wo sie als einzelfall
haben der schweizer flog markieren
meine rundenzeiten okay dann doch nicht
aus bosheit tolle zeit und erklärt dass
sie durchaus bereit sind sagt ja doch
als marie und brauche sagen muss aber
auch ja für die leckere saubere sache
die b2 und brot fuchs falle des akkus -
verarbeiten und 12 polarfuchs von sinn
féin löcher vom schritt oder sie sind
kaputt wegen verletzung ihrer hand
denn diese blicke schweizer rotfuchs
verbraucht werde tötet willst viel geld
seite aber der schätzt dass nummer ein
zehntel für den fall genutzt wird der
rest lernt im obwohl er kann bilder vor
den riesigen für sus finisher zucht und
jetzt hier mit als monster fixed
bezeichnen die riesige tier wenn sie das
gesehen was halten sie davon
also will das ist nur das was ich zu
machen und auch nicht sinnvoll findet
muss sagen dass die textilindustrie wo
einfach als textil wort ohne das verbot
und drückt und wir als kirchen muss ich
schon sagen also auch eine frau bin ich
überhaupt nicht interessiert weil ich
verlaufsformen polarfuchs oder silber 6
dann sind normal groß sie willigt
besonders brauche ich keine brüche und
mode-ikone brauche was ich hingegen
eigentlich nur schlimmer finde nicht
einmal synthetik hat es erdöl mit viel
energie ufer und umweltverschmutzung
bisher stellt wo soll eigentlich ist
naturprodukt wir auf der anderen seite
schmeißt das finde ich eigentlich
verrückten häuser gesellschaft fast nur
fünfter
häufig macht der kapuze an der luft
heute ist zum ersten mal seit langem
terrorismus stillos und schlussendlich
rundungen abzeichne
ich sehe das als produkt aus susanne
thon hatten die bombe die form und die
niederlande eine tasche der thomas
austria überrascht mich nicht dass es
der branche kritische stimme zu tier aus
form halten als die reporter aus
finnland sie jetzt sind
was findet zum thema pelz würde die pelz
kaufen und auch lecker oder viele
details das korn ich bin gespannt auf
eure kommentare